Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt, mein Name ist Tim Brittlav und hier ist Ausgabe neununddreißig.
Und ja heute geht's wieder mal wie soll es anders sein, um das Corona-Thema, aber diesmal
nicht den Pavel eingeladen, diesmal kein Corona Wikli, heute werden mal nicht die Zahlen massiert und analysiert, sondern heute wollte ich mal ein bisschen äh anderen Kontext bieten
und einen Blick auf die gesamte Impfstoffdiskussion werfen.
Und dazu braucht's dringend Expertentum und das habe ich mir mal reingeholt in Form von Lars, nämlich Lars Fischer. Hallo Lars.
Moin Kims.
Lars, du bist ja selber Wissenschaftler, du bist ähm.
Als Chemiker gestartet, aber mittlerweile auch so ein bisschen so ein universal Kommunikator, ist so ein bisschen mein äh Eindruck und arbeitest ja glaube ich auch primär als Wissenschaftsjournalist richtig.
Korrekt.
Das auch schon ziemlich lange, oder?
Seit inzwischen dreizehn Jahren, nach zwölf Jahren, je nachdem, wie man rechnet. Aber ja, schon eine Weile.
Genau und da bist du dann auch äh bekannt wie ein äh bunter Hund oder Fisch müsste hier eher sagen, weil du hast das äh Fischblock, was einerseits so ein bisschen deine Homepage ist, aber auch äh bei
den Science Blogs quasi der Ort deiner fortwährenden kommunizierenden Expertise ist.
Tatsächlich bei den Side Rocks von Spektrum DE.
Was habe ich gesagt? Science Blogs, Silox, Entschuldigung, ja natür.
Die Konkurrenz.
An, Entschuldigung, das äh war natürlich jetzt noch ein kleiner Faupa.
Einfach zu merken den Namen. Also.
Ja. Okay, die ähm Spektrum DE steckt dahinter und äh weiß nicht, wie oft kommunizierst du da, was hast du da so für eine Regelmäßigkeit.
Sehr unregelmäßig tatsächlich. Also dieses Jahr.
Habe ich schon geschafft, so ein bis zwei Mal im Monat, aber es gab eben auch in den letzten Jahren Phasen, wo es dann drei, vier Monate einfach
einfach gar nicht gegen äh manchmal aus gesundheitlichen Gründen, manchmal Motivationsgründe
Das ist ja nichts Professionelles. Das ist mein privater Spaßblog. Manchmal ist halt kein Spaß.
Ja, derzeit ist es auch ein bisschen schwierig, äh viel Spaß zu haben, ne? Auf der anderen Seite eine, eine Herausforderung, weil du hast es ja so ein bisschen mit den
Mit den solchen und den und dem Weltuntergang habe ich so den Eindruck, bin ein äh großer Freund von deinem YouTube Format. Wir werden alle sterben
wo du ja im Prinzip schon alle äh erdenklichen Methoden aufgezählt hast, wie man sich so selbst dem Untergang weihen kann.
Wie lange machst du das schon? Auch schon eine Weile, ne?
Auch eine Weile ja angefangen haben wir zweitausendzwölf.
Das mit den Seuchen ist tatsächlich etwas was schon sehr früh im Studium angefangen hat, also zweitausendsechs rum, da bin ich fünfzehn, zwanzig Jahre
schon so ein bisschen dran. Also das ist meine meine zweite Liebe neben der Chemie.
Und warum?
Weil wir generell Infektionskrankheiten einfach faszinierend sind, fremdartig, raffiniert, einfach faszinierend.
Was fasziniert dich daran.
Also,
Man hat einfach sehr viele Ebenen, zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt das Cona Virus aktuell nimmt, dann hat man auf der einen Seite die Epidemieologische Ebene ähm
also quasi die Ausbreitung, die Ausbreitung, Dynamik, zum Beispiel mit dieser Frage nach den Supersportarten, nach der Frage nach dem Virusmutation, nach den Viruslinien, der Virulenz.
Es ist die eine Seite, auf der anderen Seite hat man dann so Geschichten des Virus, packt seine.
Ärgern a in die Zelle und dann hat die Zelle schon eigene Mechanismen Fremderin ab
zu fangen und die Chorona vielen haben ihrerseits Mechanismen um diese diese Mechanismen äh zu unterlaufen. Also es gib
Es gibt da ganz viele verschiedene Ebenen, die sehr komplex sind, die sehr komplex miteinander interagieren. Ähm.
Da ist also da ist also sehr viel zu holen. Das ist aus meiner Sicht eigentlich eins der spannendsten Gebiete der Naturwissenschaft, einfach weil so vielschichtig ist.
Da frage ich mich ja, warum denn ich Biologie studiert hast?
Das war im Wesentlichen Zufall tatsächlich. Äh ich bin in die Chemie rein gerutscht, weil ich.
Während meiner Schulzeit tatsächlich die Gelegenheit gekriegt habe, eine chemisch-technische Ausbildung
neben dem Abitur parallel dazu zu machen, das heißt, ich hatte da mein Abitur und eine fertige abgeschlossene Ausbildung als Miettechniker
Das ist natürlich, das war natürlich eine Gelegenheit, die ich nicht.
Nicht vorbeigehen lassen konnte und deswegen bin ich in der Chemie gelandet.
Okay, nachvollziehbar. Aber trotzdem äh hast du da sozusagen eine eine biologische Ader auch äh weiterverfolgt.
Ja, durchaus. Ich habe eine ganze Menge Interessen gebietet tatsächlich.
Jetzt hast du dich natürlich, äh, wie sollte es auch anders sein, auch mit der ganzen Saatkopf zwei Problematik schon vielfältig auseinandergesetzt, diverse Blogartikel dazu auch.
Geschrieben, unterschiedliche Einschätzungen sowohl was so statistischen Ansätze betrifft als eben auch ja die Erkenntnislage mit begleitet.
Was sind so dein Eindruck wie.
Ähm wie der Fortschritt so ist im Erkenntnisgewinn über was dieses Virus eigentlich ist und macht.
Ich bin tatsächlich äh.
Sehr überrascht und auch sehr positiv überrascht darüber in welchem Ausmaß und mit welcher Geschwindigkeit wir
neue Erkenntnisse aller Art bekommen und auch vor allem belastbare Erkenntnisse.
Äh über das Virus. Also da fließen jetzt ganz massiv Ressourcen rein und nicht nur
Ressourcen, sondern da ist auch viel Kooperation, da geht viel Expertise auch aus benachbarten
Gebieten rein, da wird viel interdisziplinär gearbeitet. Also wir lernen sehr schnell sehr viel.
Und klar ist da auch ähm sehr viel
Blödsinn dazwischen, manchmal beabsichtigt, manchmal unbeabsichtigt, aber im Großen und Ganzen ist der Erkenntnisgewinn jetzt während dieser dieser Pandemie.
Teilweise in einigen Gebieten wirklich atemberaubend, nicht nur im Zoo auf das Kona-Virus, sondern auf äh Panemine im Allgemeinen, auf Birologie im Allgemeinen
Das ist schon eine sehr spannende Zeit aus wissenschaftlicher Hinsicht.
Gib mal ein Beispiel, was was dich da jetzt äh überrascht hat, was deine Erwartungen äh überstiegen hat.
Also zum einen äh haben wir gesehen, nachdem wir ganz schnell äh
die Testentwicklung, das ging ja ganz, ganz, ganz Sex äh
wirklich innerhalb von Tagen die Erbsequenz da war, dann war
paar Tage später schon der PCR-Test vorhanden. Äh
dann quasi in der gleichen Forschungslinie auf der auf der Basis der Gensequenzen dieses Virus wurde dann gleich mit der Impfstoffentwicklung begonnen ohne ohne dass man überhaupt das Virus erstmal isolieren und heranzüchten musste. Das war natürlich
das ging auch nur dank der neuen
Methoden der Impfstoffentwicklung, der neuen Impfprinzipien, DNA RNA im Stoffe, Adenoviros, Impfstoffe. Da reden wir ja gleich noch drüber.
Er soll das ging viel schneller, äh was viel schneller ging, als ich erwartet hatte, war auch
die die Verfolgung der Muttertion der einzelnen Abstammungslinien und damit natürlich gar nicht mal so der Verfolgung der Veränderungen der Viruseigenschaften, aber Verfolgung der Abstammungslinien, also wir haben
unglaublich detailliertes Bild dadrüber, wie sich dieses Virus verbreitet, welche Dynamik äh sich da entwickelt. Also ähm das hat einerseits.
Analytische Gründe mit der mit der neuen
Äh mit der neuen Gensequenzierung, das kann man ja alles sehr gut lesen und das hat auch organisatorische Gründe.
Also das, das klappt super. Man äh.
Durchaus ausgehend von der von der Gensequenz äh.
Hat man hat meine sehr schnell sehr früh ein sehr gutes Epidemiologisches Bild gehabt und auch sehr schnell Möglichkeiten bekommen mit diesem Virus umzugehen. Also wir sind sehr schnell sehr weit gekommen dabei.
Vielleicht mal so aus zum zum Verständnis, weil mich das am Anfang auch schon so ein bisschen überrascht hat. Eine Krankheit tritt auf
Und wir wissen ja jetzt nicht so ganz genau, wann es wirklich angefangen hat. Also ich glaube, da gibt's ja unterschiedliche Berichte. Klar, das hat sich dann alles gegen Ende letzten Jahres verdichtet, aber ähm.
Ich glaube, man kann schon davon ausgehen, dass es ja in irgendeiner Form schon eine Art äh.
Dieologisches Geschehen gehabt haben dürfte in den Monaten zuvor, bevor das dann sozusagen als solches auch sichtbar wurde, dass man wirklich auch den Verdacht bekommen hat in China. Oha
hier haben wir es unter Umständen mit einer neuen ansteckenden Krankheit zu tun.
Aber wie kommt man denn dann quasi überhaupt dahin zu erkennen, oh Leute kriegen hier Probleme, sterben auch hin zu.
Das muss wohl ein Virus sein und dann jetzt suchen wir das und finden das auch. Also.
Man muss ja auch erstmal wissen, dass es da ist, man muss ja wissen, wo man überhaupt gucken äh muss. Hast du da eine Erklärung, wie es dazu so schnell kam, dass man dann so bewusste Ahaja ist, Virus und.
Ist genau der Virus und genau da finden wir das Ding.
Das verdanken wir aus meiner Sicht tatsächlich.
Einerseits äh dem Saarschock von zweitausenddrei und andererseits der ähm sehr intensiven, intensiven Suche nach Emerging des Jesus in den letz
paar Jahren. Also es ist ja, es ist ja nicht so, dass man das durch Zufall gefunden hat, sondern seit zehn, fünfzehn Jahren sind wirklich.
Weltweit
Leute, ganze Forschungsteams auf der Suche nach solchen neu auftauchenden Krankheiten, zum Beispiel Spogelgrippe, via Wash H fünf, wenn eins, Wasser, Wasser, ein
Wir wollen, dass man dann relativ schnell als potenziellen Seuchenerreger ausgemacht hatte ähm.
Gab auch noch ein paar andere Vogelgrippeviren, die dabei aufgetaucht sind. Niepa hat man hat man ein bisschen im Blick äh
Ebola ist auch immer wieder so ein Wir-Watch, das dabei auftaucht und da gab's ja auch eine,
Epidemie in Westafrikas, bei der man auch wieder auf die harte Tour sehr viel gelernt hat über Viren und Emerging des hieß es.
Also es ist schon so, dass man seit geraumer Zeit damit rechnet
so was passiert, dass sowas irgendwo auf der Welt auftaucht und möglicherweise eine
eine Pandemie auftauscht wirst. Also es ist es ist schon so, dass man seit Jahren eigentlich drauf wartet, dass sowas passiert.
Ja. Aber wie findet man denn konkret, dass,
das Virus, also wie vor allem, ich meine, man hat ja erstmal keinen Test darauf, also man muss es ja erstmal finden irgendwo. Man muss ja erstmal wissen, okay, da ist es und ich schaue da jetzt drauf und und das ist auch der Auslöser wie wie kriegt man das hin.
Wir sind ja tatsächlich in der äh im Zeitalter der Gentechnik und heutzutage
nimmt man dann ähm bei Erkrankten
Blutproben, Gewebeproben, reinigt das Erbgut auf, vervielfältigt das Erbgut und benutzt dann quasi verschiedene Gensorten, die für verschiedene
Klassen von Krankheit der Gegner typisch sind. Also äh.
Zum Beispiel gibt es, gibt es bestimmte Sonden, mit denen man äh mit denen man erstmal Grippeviren identifizieren kann. Ähm natürlich Corona Viren. Er soll.
Es gibt ja auch keine komplett neuen Viren oder nur sehr wenige, muss man, muss man vorsichtshalber sagen, aber äh wir kennen die.
Bedeutend Viren, Familien äh die Krankheiten bei Menschen auslösen können, Krankheiten bei Säugetieren auslösen
wir wissen, wir kennen diese Familien, das heißt, man kann überhaupt erstmal gucken, ist da überhaupt ein Virus präsent, dass
zu einer dieser Familien gehört äh na ja und dann da muss man halt gucken, da muss man das Erbgut dieses Virus rausfischen und
die Gensequenz bestimmen, gucken wo das Ding hergehört, äh hingehört, zum Beispiel in in diesem Fall in die Abstammungslinie vom Saas von zweitausenddrei
das sind sind ja einigermaßen ähnliche Viren. Also man kann heutzutage tatsächlich,
relativ schnell mit dieser äh mit dieser DNA-Technologie äh Ergan Technologie mit dieser mit dieser Erbgutanalyse relativ schnell auch rausfinden, was
drin rumschwimmt.
Was muss ich mir unter der Gensonde vorstellen.
Im Prinzip im Prinzip das Gleiche, was man für den PCR-Test benutzt. Das sind das sind ähm,
Ich hoffe, ich rede da jetzt keine Runde, weil das schon eine ganze Weile her ist, dass ich mir das genauer angeguckt habe, wie dieser PCR-Test funktioniert. Aber tatsächlich nimmt man.
Dazu kleine Erbgutabschnitte äh das sind sogenannte Primers, das heißt.
Binden an die virale RNA in dem Fall und sorgen dann sorgen dann dafür, dass auf der anderen Seite ein komplementärer DNA-Strang entsteht
Und dann gibt es einen zweiten Primer, der dann wiederum den komplementären DNA-Strang äh erzeugt. Das hei
das heißt, man packt diesen Primer, der sehr spezifisch für dieses Virus oder eben auch für diese Virenklasse ist, packt man in die Mischung.
Packt man die Bausteine der DNA dazu und dann lässt man eben diese diesen PCR-Mechanismus durchlaufen und wenn, wenn Virale
in dieser Probe ist ähm dann wird.
Diese diese Erbgutsequenz vervielfältigt und dadurch, dass sie vervielfältigt wird. Kann man diese diese entstehende große Menge an äh an der dann auch messen.
Verstehe, das heißt man man geht einfach davon aus, okay, hier könnte eine Art Virus drin sein, aus einer Kategorie, die wir kennen, wie zum Beispiel eben Corona Viren. Und wir haben jetzt hier,
ein Material, was äh wenn man das jetzt in eine Mischung reingibt, wo eben so ein Virus präsent ist, der da sozusagen drauf
anspricht und dann einfach anfängt, sich zu replizieren. Und das ist dann für mich als äh analysierende Person quasi das Signal aha okay. Hier ist
Corona, Viren Aktivität, jetzt schauen wir doch mal genauer äh hin, um was es sich denn für welche handelt. Das sind etwa richtig verstanden.
Ist ja auch das ist ja auch die die Diskussion beim PCR-Test
Beispiel wie viel äh wie oft man die DNA quasi vervielfachen muss, um sie zu detektieren und was das bedeutet. Also es, es geht wirklich darum, wenn man diese
Wenn man diese DNA-Sorten, diese Primer da drin hat äh und die Virus,
Renau oder DNA ist da drin, dann äh dann bekommt man ein großes Signal an vervielfältigter DNA.
Gut.
Wir können also zusammenfassen insgesamt die Fortschritte sind bemerkenswert. So, es geht schnell voran.
Was gesagt, ab und zu ist auch mal was äh wie hast du dich ausgedrückt, was Blödsinn dazwischen, auch absichtlich? Äh war das deine Formu.
Ja, es gibt ja es gibt ja doch eine ganze Menge Leute ähm.
Na ja, in Corona ist jetzt das heiße Thema im heißen Thema ist Geld drin, im äh im heißen Thema ist auch Reputation zu erwerben und da gibt
da gibt es schon Leute, die da auf die ein oder andere Weise versuchen ähm.
Persönlich mehr persönlich davon zu profitieren als zum Forschungsstand beizutragen, will ich mal sagen
äh in der also wie viel davon jetzt unredlich ist und wie viel einfach nur quasi persönlicher Druck ist, will ich gar nicht im Detail beurteilen, aber ja
Es gibt ja, es gibt halt Leute, die so ein so ein bisschen die rumschludern.
Gut, die wollen wir jetzt erstmal äh ignorieren. Jetzt haben wir ähm natürlich eine wilde Diskussion rund um Impfstoffe und du hast ja schon gesagt, okay, Impfstoffe.
Sind relativ früh angegangen worden, weil man eben A früh festgestellt hat, aha, Corona Virus, dann schnell festgestellt hat.
Neu, ist außer Saaßfamilie, ist aber nochmal anders, dann konnte dieser Test entwickelt werden, der eben sehr spezifisch auf genau dieses eine Virus äh testet und,
ist ja auch, sagen wir mal, immer noch der Goldstandard bei beim Testen heute äh weltweit ist es eigentlich so, dass.
Äh der wurde äh in der Charité dann entwickelt, dieser Test, ne? Dieser PCR-Test, den er heute alle verwenden.
Und das ist auch der einzige, der weltweit zum Einsatz kommt oder sind da mittlerweile noch andere zum Einsatz.
Nein, nein äh das äh.
Das Prinzip ist ja relativ simpel. Man benutzt eben diese bestimmten DNA-Stücke, die zur Virus RNA passen. Aber es gibt natürlich sehr viele unterschiedliche
Oder es gibt einige unterschiedliche Möglichkeiten wie man das letztendlich so realisieren kann äh dass es
Erstens äh das Virus auch, wenn es sich genetisch verändert, immer noch zuverlässig, die De
kehrt äh wie man das zum Beispiel vom ursprünglichen Saß und von Human, Korona Viren, also mit von den vorhandenen Erkältungsschwieren unterscheidet.
Meines Wissens gibt es da sehr viele unterschiedliche Testvarianten ähm.
Natürlich in dem Moment, in dem man weiß, dass es funktioniert, kann man ja einfach diese diese äh diese Primer, diese DNA-Sonnen einfach austauschen gegen irgendwas, was.
Möglicherweise besser funktioniert. Da gibt es sehr viele Varianten.
Okay.
Und das war jetzt aber dann quasi auch die Bestätigung, okay, alles klar mit dem Test, wir finden dieses Virus immer wieder. Wir wissen, worum es jetzt hier geht. Wir wissen, was der eigentliche Angreifer äh ist im System. Jetzt.
Wollen wir doch mal schauen, ob wir in der Lage sind,
ein Mittel zu entwickeln, was dem Menschen sozusagen bevor das Virus Schaden nehmen kann, hier schon Reaktionen zeigt. Das ist ja im Prinzip so der klassische Ansatz des Impfens, dass man
dem Menschen in irgendeiner Form eine Substanz verabreicht, die den Körper zu einer Reaktion bewegen, die quasi.
Eigentlich erst stattfindet, wenn der, wenn das richtige Virus auftaucht, aber die quasi schon vorgezogen reagiert und entsprechende Schutzmaßnahmen aktiviert, dass wenn das eilige Virus kommt
dann schon nichts wirklich dramatisches mehr passieren kann. Ähm jetzt ist die Frage, wo.
Greift man dann an. Also was sind sozusagen die klassischen äh ähm Dinge auf auf die man jetzt mit so einem Impfstoff hinzielt.
Und hat das jetzt in der aktuellen Situation eigentlich noch bestand oder müssen jetzt hier andere Maßnahmen ergriffen werden.
Normalerweise oder klassisch ähm benutzt man als
Im Stoff Virus Bestandteile oder inaktivierte Viren äh die man eben in den Körper spritzt und die erzeugen eine
eine Reaktion in Form von Antikörpern im Blut, also äh.
Dieser Antikörper binden dann idealerweise und das tun sie dann auch oft an denen Teil des Virus, mit dem.
Dass wir was ein menschliche Zellen bindet und in äh in menschliche Zellen eindringt und von, wenn dieser Form Impfstoff induzierten Antikörper jetzt ihrerseits an diese Bindungsmotive äh.
Binden, dann kann das Wirrosch nicht mehr in die Zelle eindringen und das dann neutralisiert. Deswegen nennt man solche Antikörperneutralisieren und das sind die Antikörper, die man bei einer äh
die man bei einer klassischen Impfreaktion idealerweise bekommt. Die zirkulieren dann im Blut
und fangen die Viren ab.
Die haben aber durchaus einige Nachteile oder dieses dieses Prinzip des äh.
Das Einspritzen von inaktivierten Viren oder Virus Bestandteilen, die haben ähm
Das hat den Nachteil, dass es das Immunsystem nur zum Teil aktiviert. Auf der einen Seite kann man das äh ein bisschen ausgleichen durch die sogenannten Adiuvantien. Ähm.
Die die Immunreaktion verstärken, die eine stärkere Immunreaktion provozieren und ähm dadurch natürlich auch eine stärkere Immunität erzeugen.
Gerade bei Viren ist aber das Problem auch, dass Viren normalerweise eine sehr spezifische
Immunität hervorrufen und der Immunreaktion hervorrufen, die nur dann entsteht, wenn das Virus oder sein Erbgut in die Zellen reingeht. Und das tun ja inaktivierte Viren nicht und deswegen ähm
sind diese diese Immunreaktionen auf klassische im Stoff, auf inaktivierte im Stoff oder Virus Bestandteile äh sind.
Oft nicht so effektiv wie zum Beispiel äh die Immunität, die durch eine durchgemachte Infektion entsteht,
Also das heißt die klassische, die klassische Impfung erzeugt, neutralisierende Antikörper im Blut.
Aber diese Immunreaktion ist eben nicht immer nicht immer ausreichend.
Was heißt denn genau inaktivierte Viren? Was was muss man denn mit so einem Virus machen, damit er inaktiv wird? Ist das nur das entfernt? Also man man muss ja.
Dieses äh also das, wo womit in die Zelle eingedrückt ist, ist dieses Spike Protein, von dem wir sprechen, ne?
Ja, wobei man inaktiviert, Viren meines Wissens tatsächlich äh durch abgutschädigende äh
Chemikalien oder Bestrahlung.
Wobei ich da in den Details tatsächlich nicht Firmen bin, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Er war auf jeden auf jeden Fall haben diese inaktivierten Viren noch das Spike-Protein. Sie haben also dieses Motiv.
Mit dem das Virus an die Zellen bindet, aber sie können die Zellen nicht mehr aktiv infizieren.
Also das heißt das Erbgut wird geschädigt.
Aber trotzdem okay, aber trotzdem wird eine Antikörperreaktion ausgelöst, die aber nicht ganz so effektiv ist, als wenn das Virus tatsächlich schon in die Zelle eingedrungen wäre.
Genau, weil beim Eindringen dieser dieser Virus Ärgern A in die Zelle laufen.
Ganz eigene laufen ganz spezifische Immunprozesse ab die eben,
eine
eine spezifische antivirale äh Reaktion in Gang setzen, die auch eine stärkere, zelluläre Immunantwort bedingen, also ähm.
Zum Beispiel werden dadurch ähm T-Zellen stimuliert, die.
Genau darauf gedreht sind infizierte Zellen zu zerstören. Und dieser dieser Aktivierungsweg, das ist ein ganz wichtiger.
Ist ein ganz wichtiger Weg, um äh
Wir wollen Infektionen einzufangen, also einfach infizierte Körperzellen sofort zu zerstören. Und diese diese Teezellen, diese Immunzellen, die das können, die werden viel stärker innotieren, wenn eben diese Signalwege.
Angeregt werden, die angeregt werden, wenn wir nahe ärgernah in die Zelle eindring
Das ist der entscheidende Punkt. Wenn das nicht passiert, hat man quasi nur eine Immunreaktion auf das fremde Protein
dass deine Blutzirkuliert, aber eben nicht die ganz große Immunalarmsirene, die losgeht, wenn irgendwas in die Zellen eindringt.
Trotzdem ist das natürlich etwas, was was verfolgt wird, oder? Dieser, diese Herangehensweise, weil sie quasi nah naheliegend und erprobt ist.
Genau, also das ist äh soweit, ich weiß, ist das auch das dritthäufigste verfolgte Prinzip, dass man einfach
Man macht das ja auch beim Grippevirus, man züchtet, dass Virus inaktiviert das Ding, äh das ist, wie du gesagt hast, es ist bewährt, das ist
Natürlich versuchen versuchen auch Arbeitsgruppen und Unternehmen heute nach diesem Prinzip zu arbeiten. Ähm.
Allerdings gibt es Hinweise darauf, dass das.
Corona Viros spezifisch bei Corona Viren, äh kein besonders erfolgversprechender Einsatz ist tatsäch.
Angenommen es wäre Erfolg äh äh ausreichend Erfolgsversprechen, also dass man sagen kann, okay
hilft nicht bei allen, aber hilft bei vielen und hat keine Nebenwirkungen oder so, jetzt mal so rein hypothetisch gedacht, wie schwierig sind denn diese
Arten von inaktiviert, also wie wie könnte man so einen Impfstoff auf Basis von inaktivierten Viren herstellen? Also es ist das Herstellungsprinzip auch schon so verbreitet, dass man das dann in großen Mengen machen kann, weil das ja auch mal noch so ein Faktor ist.
Nach meinem Verständnis leider der große Haken für inaktivierte Impfstoffe äh
möchten, die Viren erstmal getröchtet werden, wir müssen kurtisiert werden, äh sie müssen sehr, sehr, sehr große Mengen dann hergestellt werden. Äh man braucht eine Qualitätskontrolle, dass sie während dieser während dieser Vermehrung
bei Grippe im Stoffen ist das zum Beispiel in Eiern, ne? Man muss gucken, dass während dieser Vermehrung da nicht irgendwelche Mutationen auf
treten, die irgendwelchen Ärger machen können. Man muss die Vieren aufreinigen. Äh man muss sie effektiv zerstören
Man muss die Qualität kontrollieren, das dauert alles sehr, sehr, sehr lange.
Beim Grippe im Stoff dauert es zum Beispiel sehr so lange, dass man
ein Jahr vor Beginn der Saison, also quasi schon während der Saison im Jahr davor, anfangen muss, diese diese Impfstoffe zu entwickeln und wenn dann irgendwie zwei, drei Monate vor Beginn der Saison sich ab
zeichnet. Wir brauchen jetzt viel mehr im Stoff oder wir brauchen jetzt einen anderen Impfstoff, dann ist es wegen dieser
langen Zeiträume für die Produktion ist es dann einfach zu spät
Das ist beim Corona Virus im Stoff natürlich, dass das Problem, wenn wir sagen, oh, wir haben jetzt einen funktionierenden, inaktivierten Impfstoff äh wir produzieren jetzt mal Impfdosen für.
Acht Milliarden Menschen. Ähm ja, da sind wir zweitausendzweiundzwanzig noch dabei.
Okay. Na gut
Muss ja nicht der einzige Impfstoff bleiben so. Ich denke es äh generell kein Fehler vielgleisig zu fahren, weil man kann ja auch immer noch überrascht werden, aber äh trotzdem ist auch klar, dass es vielleicht nicht das Einzige, woran man forschen sollte.
Nee, also das ist ähm etwas, was Fachleute aus verschiedenen Gründen von Anfang an sagen, dass man mehrere Impfstoffe braucht, parallel, dass man auch mehrere
Klassen von Impfstoffen braucht. Äh einerseits weil mehrere Arten von Impfstoffen natürlich auch
möglicherweise parallel produziert werden äh möglicherweise funktionieren
bestimmte Impfstoffe bei bestimmten Personengruppen besser als bei anderen. Für diese anderen Personengruppen sind dann andere Impfstofftypen oder andere Impfstoffe sinnvoller
Das weiß man nicht und man möchte da natürlich möglichst viele Pfeile im Köcher haben äh und natürlich können wir jetzt auch nicht quasi.
Impfstoffentwicklung stoppen, sondern einen Kandidaten hat, dann geht man erstmal viertel Jahr ran und testet den und wenn der, wenn der nichts ist, entwickelt man irgendwas anderes weiter, sondern äh.
Die Impfstoffentwicklung ist tatsächlich ein ist tatsächlich einer der Bereiche ähm der.
Sehr viel schneller geht grade, als man das gewohnt ist und als ich auch erwartet hätte, einfach weil so viel parallel passiert, auch weil so viel kooperativ passiert. Also ähm
wirklich alle Arten von Impfstoffen.
Aller Arten von Prinzipien, alle Arten von Produktionsmethoden werden im Moment parallel vorangetrieben. Äh deswegen
Einerseits deswegen, weil alle sagen, man braucht viele Impfstoffe und andererseits deswegen, weil wir auch nicht wissen, welche am Ende funktioniert.
Und weil wie du schon äh gesagt hast, gerade so nebenbei.
Ist ja auch sehr, sehr wohl sein kann, dass ein Nimpfstoff, der vielleicht nicht so optimal ist, den man eben nicht
in großen Mengen produzieren kann. Trotzdem sicher als besonders effektiv für eine bestimmte Zielgruppe äh herausstellt. Sagen wir mal, alte Leute oder Leute mit ähm irgendwelchen schwierigen Vorerkrankungen, die in anderen Impfstoffen unter Umständen gar nicht vertragen würden.
Ja, hinaus.
Was gibt's denn jetzt noch für weitere Ansätze.
Ja, ich hätte ja gesagt, ein äh Impfstoff speziell äh
bei Viren funktioniert besser, wenn man irgendetwas hat, was ärgernau oder DNA äh.
In die menschlichen Zellen einschleust und dabei die diese spezifische, antivirale.
Antiviralen äh Mechanismen in Gang setzt äh und.
Gibt eben neben den inaktivierten Impfstoffen äh und neben den.
Auf auf Bestandteilen basierten Impfstoffen gibt es eben auch Prinzipien, die das leisten, zum Beispiel einerseits Impfstoffe, die aus mehr oder weniger nackter Erdon A oder DNA
basieren und es gibt sogenannte Vektorimpfstoffe, bei denen quasi in irgendein harmloses, aber aktives Virus so ein Stückchen ähm
Coronna Viorosh, Ren A, beziehungsweise DNA, je nach Gyros, Vektor eingebaut wird. Ähm.
Und dieser sogenannte Vektor, also das harmlose Virus.
Dann quasi die Virus DNA oder in die Zelle hinein und ähm.
Ja, also so dass.
Erst erstens die Immunreaktion in Gang läuft und zweitens dieses Hyrosprotein auch äh produziert wird.
Mhm. Kann ich mir das so ein bisschen vorstellen, als als ob man quasi nur also ein Teil des Nummernschilds äh nimmt und versucht, darüber auch schon äh Reaktionen zu äh erzielen. Also ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt der.
Eindringende Virus äh angegriffen wird und eine Immunreaktion hervorstellt äh hervorruft.
Über seine komplette DNA-Information oder RNA-Information, sondern eben nur bestimmte Teile davon, dass man eben nur bestimmte Teile nimmt.
Sagt OK hier kannst du drauf reagieren liebe Zelle, mach mal ordentlich Antikörper, mach mal äh fiese Teezellen, die betroffene Zellen dann gleich vernichten.
Aber wir haben, sagen wir mal, den den Rest dieser Erbinformation, der jetzt hier auch wirklich Schaden anrichten kann, haben wir gar nicht dabei. Wenn wir das so vorstellen.
Genauso kann man sich das vorstellen. Also äh
Celle erkennen, virale in diesem Fall zum Beispiel Ergana daran äh
dass sie bestimmte chemische Markierungen hat oder nicht hat, also äh virale ärgern auch oder DNA kann von der Zelle, von äh
von normaler, also körperlicher, ärgernau oder DNA unterschieden werden. Äh und wenn eben dieser Unterschied.
Bemerkt wird, dann geht der Alarm los, dann wird also diese dieses Erbgut identifiziert und.
Quasi die diese antiviralen Signalwege in Gang gesetzt
Also dazu muss gar nicht die komplette Virale, das komplette virale Erdbeut vorhanden sein, damit das damit dieser äh Prozess anläuft, das ist etwas. Das hat man schon vor ganz geraumer Zeit festgestellt. Das ist der zweite Punkt
Ähm.
Obwohl das virale Air gut auch diese diese nackte Ärgernah oder DNA. Obwohl das vom von der Zelle erkrankt wird, wird das von der Zelle gleichzeitig auch im im Proteinomgesetz.
Die dann äh nach außen präsentiert werden. Das ist quasi die zweite Komponente. Man hat äh man hat nicht nur die äh.
Quasi die Alarmfunktion der eindringt des eindringenden Erbguts, sondern das eindringende virale Airpod wird auch ausgelesen
in Proteininformationen übersetzt, das sind allerdings in diesem Fall nur sehr kleine Peptidfragmente ähm die auf der Zelle präsentiert werden und die dann eben auch ähm.
Das an äh das äh das adaptive Immunsystem stimulieren, also in dem Fall einerseits die äh.
Die Teezellen, die infizierte Zellen vernichten, die erkennen diese viralen Fragmente.
Antikörper erkennen ebenfalls diese viralen Fragmente, die dann.
Die dann auf der Basis dieses Herbgguts produziert werden. Deswegen
reicht es quasi aus, nur ein Teil des viralen Airpus reinzupacken und
für diese für diese virale Erkennung des adaptiven Immunsystems, das ist natürlich besonders praktisch, wenn das Spike-Protein diese äh,
quasi da eingeschleust wird in Form seiner seiner DNA oder denn wenn die Zellen quasi Fragmente des Spice Proteins auf der Oberfläche präsentieren.
Dann reagiert das adaptive Immunsystem gleich auf das Spike-Protein, mit dem das Virus äh
mit dem das auf die Zähnen an die Zellen bindet und dadurch kann es dann wieder auch
zum Beispiel diese neutralisierenden Antikörper erzeugen. Wir haben also diese diese zwei Komponenten auf der einen Seite
die antivirale Alarmantwort innerhalb der Zelle auf der anderen Seite.
Äh dadurch, dass ich spezifische Krona-Virus spezifisches Corona Viruserbut ist
ähm dann eben auch die konkrete Erkennung des Korona Virus durch die durch die adaptive Immunantwort.
Und ähm das bildet dann auch starke Antikörper aus.
Das wird sich zeigen müssen, das ist ein bisschen das Problem mit den neuen Methoden, mit den Erb,
basierten Methoden äh, dass die sich gerade beim Menschen noch nicht so richtig bewiesen haben. Also ähm.
Zum Beispiel hat man bei Ärgern auch der DNA im Stoffen o
das Problem, das ist zwar theoretisch und in gerade in kleinen Tieren, in Mäusen durchaus sehr gut funktionieren äh bei
Menschen aber nur eine unzureichende Immunantwort rauslösen. Und da wird noch viel Forschung betrieben wie man diese Immunantwort auf diese Erdbutimpfstoffe äh besser machen kann.
Also ähm das funktioniert alles total super in der Theorie, in der Praxis haben sich diese diese
neuartigen Impfstoffprinzipien noch nicht so richtig bewährt. Das ist der große Hakens.
Wie neuartig sind die denn.
Meines Wissens gibt es noch.
Besser kein beim Menschen zugelassenen, ärgernah oder dir nah im Stoff äh bei Vektoren, also bei harmlose Viren, die mit diesen die mit einem.
Impfprotein beladen sind, also mit einem Stück Viruserbut.
Da bin ich nicht ganz sicher, ob es da nicht irgendwo außerhalb des Corona-Virus schon irgendwelche Zulassungen gibt, aber auch nicht.
Viel, also das sind alles weitgehend unbewährte Sachen und.
Es gibt auch bei äh bei tierischen Impfstoffen, also veterinärimpfstoffen.
Meines Wissens weder weder besonders viele ärgernah noch dernahe Impfstoffe. Wie gesagt, bei den Adenovieren weiß ich jetzt nicht ganz genau, wie der Stand bei der Zulassung ist, aber auch die sind relativ neu.
Also wir wissen, wir wissen de facto bei diesem bei diesem Impfstoff
Typen noch gar nicht, wie gut sie funktionieren und bei und BNA im Stoffen wissen wir sogar, dass sie, dass sie oft problematisch sind.
Aber man hat zumindest eine relativ große Hoffnung, dass wenn sie funktionieren, dass sie dann halt sehr effizient funktionieren könnten und wenn ich das richtig sehe, äh sind wären diese Impfstoffe auch relativ einfach in großen Mengen zu produzieren.
Ja, also gerade gerade ärgernau und deren äh Katze ja kannst du ja im Tonnenmaßstab
Ne, vielleicht nicht im Tonnenmaßstab, aber jetzt kannst du in sehr großen Mengen sehr schnell herstellen. Ähm
Also ja, dieser dieser Impfstoffe haben schon eine ganze Menge
Vorteile und äh wenn sie gut funktionieren, äh sind sie sicher besser als die klassischen Impfstofftypen. Äh sie sind zum Beispiel auch besser als
lebend im Stoffe. Man hat ja auch die Möglichkeit äh das Corona, das Corona Virus soweit abzuschwächen.
Das ist quasi nicht mehr krank macht, aber immer noch eine Impfreaktion äh hervorruft. Aber im Gegensatz zu lebend im Stoff haben sie nicht das Risiko.
Quasi ihre eigene Krankheit auszulösen. Sie sind also potenziell sehr sicher. Sie sind einfach und billig zu produzieren
theoretisch äh können sie auch eine super Immunantwort und eine bessere Immunantwort als inaktivierte Impfstoffe hervorrufen. Nur.
Theorie und Praxis sind eben zwei andere zwei unterschiedliche Dinge.
Okay, jetzt äh lebend im Stoffe wäre dann sozusagen die die dritte äh Variante, hast du jetzt im Prinzip ja schon äh angesprochen die Nachteile, also ist quasi das echte Virus. Auch unmodifiziert nur in geringen Mengen oder wie.
Doch modifiziert. Also.
Die Vektorimpfstoffe, die ich eben angesprochen habe, also die zum Beispiel Erdähnungsvirusimpfstoffe
die jetzt äh zum Beispiel der russische Impfstoff, der schon
zugelassen mehr oder weniger ist und der chinesische Impfstoff, das sind beides ein Denovirus, Impfstoffe. Äh die gibt es in.
Abgeschwächter oder in in aktiver Form und inaktiver Form, also es
auch lebend im Stoff als Vektorimpfstoffe, weil diese Viren vermeintlich harmlos sind. Ähm und auf der anderen Seite gibt,
quasi das Originalvirus als Leben Virus
das muss dann attenoviert werden, dass er abgeschwächt und man schwächt solche Viren dadurch ab äh.
Dass man sie immer wieder, immer, wieder, immer, immer, immer, immer, immer, immer wieder in äh verschiedenen Säugetieren, zum Beispiel Kaninchen reproduzieren das neue Kaninchenansteck so produzieren lässt und so
Wir sind, die sich zwar sehr stark vermehren
aber eben keine schwere Krankheit mehr auslösen. Dieses Attenuieren, dieses Abschwächen.
Das dauert natürlich, das dauert auch eine ganze Weile
Äh und man kann sich nie wirklich sicher sein, dass das mit der Abschwächung wirklich stimmt und dass dieses Virus auch tatsächlich.
Nach der Impfung abgeschwächt bleibt. Also ähm die lebend im Stoffe, die abgeschwächten Lebendimpfstoffe habe ich.
Eben bei der Aufstellung quasi weggelassen, weil sie aus diesen genannten Gründen keine große Rolle spielen. Sie sind
riskant, sie dauern sehr lange herzustellen, viel länger als sie inaktivierten sogar noch und
Deswegen machen das auch nicht viele Gruppen.
Na, also wir hatten jetzt.
Die ähm inaktivierten Viren, wir hatten den ARNA äh Impfstoffe und kurz über die Lindimpstoffe gesprochen, gibt's jetzt noch eine dritte Methode, mit der an Impfstoffe herangegangen wird.
Oder der vierte.
Na ja, es gibt verschiedene äh es gibt verschiedene Methoden
virale Proteine, also Spike Proteine in diesem Fall, weil wir ja dieses für die neutralisierenden Antikörper, die Spikes präsentieren wollen
Ähm.
Also man kann einfach die die Proteine herstellen und in die in die Blutbahn geben. Es gibt aber auch zum Beispiel Virus ähnliche Partikel. Äh das sind auch verschieden auf verschiedenen Wege hergestellte so ein
Membranbläschen, die ähnlich wie das echte Virus mit Spike Proteinen besetzt sind. Äh die.
Diese diese äh Techniken haben im Grunde,
einen ähnlichen Nachteil, den ähnlichen Nachteil, wie inaktivierte Viren, äh dass sie tatsächlich nur die, die Immunantwort im Blut auslösen und keine, keine zellublere
Also nicht die die antivirale Antwort in den Zähnen aushürschen.
Weil sie nicht für dich in der Lage sind, einzudringen in die Zellen.
Genau, sie enthalten keine, sie enthalten keine äh Gerner oder Ärgern auch, sondern sie präsentieren
Sie präsentieren quasi nur dieses Anti-Gehen, dieses dieses Proteinmotiv, auf das der Antikörper äh reagieren sollen. Der Vorteil der vermeintliche Vorteil äh
Dieses Prinzip im Vergleich zu inaktivierten Viren ist äh die Hoffnung oder auch die Tatsache, dass man, dass man solche äh
Proteine oder auch die virusartigen Partikel einfach in sehr viel größeren Mengen sehr viel schneller produzieren kann als die als die äh inaktivierten Viren
Aber auch da, also das, das ist auch schon die Impfstoffklasse an die ich nicht so recht glaub.
Und das sind jetzt sozusagen die Kandidaten oder gibt's noch weitere äh Methoden, die verfolgt werden.
Soweit ich das sehe nicht, also wir haben die, wir haben die äh
inaktivieren wir die inaktivierten wir haben die lebendige Stoffe äh wir haben die Proteine, die wir rosartigen Partikel die,
äh die Erbgut-Impfstoffe äh und die Vektorimpfstoffe. Ich glaube, wir haben sie alle.
Kann man sagen, dass jetzt äh eigentlich die Hoffnung primär auf diesen RNA basierten Impfstoffen liegt.
Weil man die in großen Mengenherz äh stellen kann und weil sie Versprechen sehr äh effektive ähm Schutzmaßnahmen auszulösen, auch wenn man noch nicht weiß, ob das gelingt.
Tatsächlich ist die sind die besten die besten Hoffnungen.
Im Moment tatsächlich die Sektorimpfstoffe, die Adenoviros Vektor im Stoff, also das sind Agenovien, Denovien sind einfach normale Erkältungsviren quasi, die keine schwere Erkrankung auslösen
Gern Erbgut wird dann grob gesagt ein Stück vom Spike Protein des Corona-Sirus eingefügt, so dass also man eine echte virale Infek
auf dieses Immunsystem auch entsprechend reagiert und äh gleichzeitig werden Teile des Bike Proteins hergestellt und dem Immunsystem präsentiert, so dass also die adaptive Immunantwort äh darauf äh
Ja, da darauf entstehen kann
Äh die haben, die haben quasi den Vorteil der DNANA, sie.
Impfstoffe, dass man eben, dass man eben das Erbgut des Virus benutzen kann
Auf der anderen Seite sind sie aber doch schon Tickbewerter und einen Tick besser erforscht als äh
Als sie Ärgerna oder Dienasien, deswegen würde ich die äh Denovirusimpfstoffe, Divektorimpfstoffe im Moment vorne sehen, auch weil eben die am weitesten entwickelten
derzeitigen Impfstoffe, das sind meines Wissens, alles Adenoverspektoren.
Mhm. Also die jetzt spezifisch auf äh Saaskoff zwei erzielen, meint so. Okay, also das ist dann quasi der russische Vorstoß.
Dass äh der russische basiert auf, ich glaube sogar zwei Adenovieren, zweier Denovieren für zwei Impfdosen
in China äh gibt es meines zwischen seinen Lebensstoff für die Armee, der ebenfalls auf Adenovian basiert. Die sind natürlich sehr, sehr, sehr schnell zugelassen worden, das heißt, man hat äh noch
keine wirklich guten Ergebnisse, ob sie tatsächlich schützen,
Aber ja, das sind offensichtlich sind das die Impfstoffe, die am schnellsten hergestellt werden können
zumindest am schnellsten erprobt werden können.
Ich meine, insofern, sofern das nicht alles alles blödsinn ist. Sofern das nicht alles Nebelkerzen, aus China oder Russland sind, aber das glaube ich in diesem Fall nicht. Ich glaube schon, dass die Impfstoffe real sind
ob sie funktionieren, wird sie aber noch zeigen müssen.
Wozu sie ja im Prinzip ja jetzt auch die Gelegenheit haben, weil wenn sie dann innerhalb von China und Russland dann zugelassen sind, bedeutet das ja im Prinzip auch, dass sie jetzt verabreicht werden.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass das denn benutzt wird. Das Problem ist dann so ein bisschen äh
woher man die Daten über die über die Wirkung kriegt und inwieweit man diesen Daten äh dann auch glauben kann, weil.
Einerseits, das ist nicht so ganz einfach.
Wir erinnern uns, wir wissen aus dem, aus dem Tierimpfstoffen gegen Corona Viren, dass wir
nicht mit einem vollständigen Schutz rechnen können. Es werden sich also trotz Impfungen noch Leute infizieren und auch krank werden, aber möglicherweise werden sich weniger infizieren und die werden auch weniger schwer krank werden
Das heißt ähm der Effekt ist nicht so deutlich,
Äh man braucht eine viel, viel, viel größere Stichprobe, um solche Effekte zu sehen. Das ist das eine, also da da ist dann die Frage, wann man solche Daten bekommt und wie gut sie sind, also wie viele Leute hier in dieser Stichprobe drin sind, wie deutlich man den Effekt
sieht
Zum Beispiel, wenn der Effekt vorhanden ist, aber nicht groß ist, dann wird das überhaupt Diskussionen dadrüber geben, ob der Effekt existiert. Und dann gibt's ja auch noch die Frage nach dem politischen Druck.
Kann sich ein Land wie Russland
zum Beispiel können die sich überhaupt erlauben, dass der Impfstoff äh dann nicht funktioniert oder dass äh
dass die Daten vielleicht vielleicht nicht
nicht ausreichen äh wenn wenn dann irgendwie zehn Millionen Leute geimpft wurden, da ist natürlich auch dieses dieses politische Problem immer, wenn sich eine Regierung dahin stellt und sagen, hurra, wir haben den Impfstoff, wir wir stecken jetzt Nadeln in so und so viele Millionen
Mit Gliederunteres Volkes und hinterher stellt sich raus, pushte Kuchen.
Schwierig, also da da wird man da wird man sehen müssen, welche Daten man bekommt, wie gut die Qualität ist, welche Schlussfolgerungen man denn überhaupt.
Und äh welche welche politischen.
Ja welche politischen Einflüsse da möglicherweise auch
mit reinspielen, ne? Das ist das ist wirklich schwer zu sagen wann und ob wir jemals Wirksamkeitsdaten von solchen Impfstoffen bekommen.
Dann.
Hat man ja auch das Problem, dass diese Impfstoffe, das wissen wir aus Tierstudien ähm nicht perfekt schützen werden, das heißt, es werden nur weniger Leute krank, es werden nur schwer krank. Das heißt, die Daten sind
keineswegs eindeutig, die man bekommen wird und man wird da statistisch auswerten müssen und dann.
Ist auch immer die Frage, na ja wir wissen auch aus der allgemeinen Forschung, auch aus der medizinischen Forschung insgesamt,
dass man äh.
Wenn man so Unklage und saubere Daten, wie man sie wahrscheinlich bekommen wird, statistisch auswertet, dann wird das kontroversen darüber geben, was diese Statistik eigentlich überhaupt aussagt. Und deswegen.
Einerseits wegen dieser unsauberen Statistik andererseits wegen des politischen und wirtschaftlichen Drucks
bin ich Teil, bin nicht nur bei diesen Impfstoffen, sondern auch bei später, wenn du es schaffen durchaus auch ein bisschen.
Welche Qualität von Evidenz wird da bekommen werden, dass die Dinge wirklich funktionieren.
Ich habe auch gehört, dass ähm das auch teilweise als gefährlich angesehen wird, solche ungetesteten Impfstoffe schon breit zur Anwendung zu bringen, weil das auch negative Auswirkungen haben kann, so für die
unter Umständen? Wählst du das für realistisch.
Puh, also äh eigentlich.
Nicht so richtig. Also es äh es gibt natürlich bei
Erbgut im Stoffen, gerade bei DNA-Impfstoffen äh immer das Problem, dass diese, dass diese.
Im GNA auch ins Erbgut eingebaut werden kann und möglicherweise in Onkogene eingebaut wird und möglicherweise Krebs erzeugt und so auf der anderen Seite.
Hat man das bei ärgernah im Stoff nicht, deswegen werden die tatsächlich bevorzugt. Ähm Tierstudien an DNA Impfstoffen zeigen, dass äh.
Dass dieser Einbau.
Auch eigentlich nicht passiert oder dass diese diese theoretische Möglichkeit gar nicht realisiert wird. Ähm.
Die größere, die größere Gefahr ist tatsächlich, weil wir ja in irgendeiner
weil wir ja in irgendeiner Weise versuchen das Immunsystem zu stimulieren, äh dass das Immunsystem dann komische Dinge macht, die möglicherweise schädlich sind. Also da gibt es ja äh.
Da gibt es ja zum Beispiel das Problem, dass Antikörper entstehen können
bei der Impfung, aber auch bei natürlichen Infektionen, die nicht neutralisierend sind, sondern die nur binden
dann aber dazu führen, dass Viren von Immunzellen aufgenommen werden und dann die Immunzellen infizieren und äh das kann äh,
kann die Erkrankung deutlich schwerer verlaufen lassen. Es gibt eben so ein paar Möglichkeiten.
Wie so eine Impfung tatsächlich schiefgehen kann, aber aus meiner Sicht ist das größere Problem.
Ist das größere Problem sind da nicht die Nebenwirkungen, sondern tatsächlich einfach die ganz reale Möglichkeit, dass in dem Stoff einfach nichts bringt.
Das wird da Millionen Menschen mit irgendwas impfen
was möglicherweise sehr selten Nebenwirkungen auslöst, aber noch seltener funktioniert tatsächlich.
Mh
Was ist denn die deine Perspektive auf die deutschen Initiativen. Da wird ja nun viel drüber äh geredet, Bundesregierung hat sich da ja auch äh sogar beteiligt. Bei einem Projekt.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe, wird ja hier in Deutschland vor allem auf diese RNA äh Virentechnik gesetzt.
Wo wir nicht wissen, ob ob was bei rauskommt sozusagen.
Äh kann ich ehrlich gesagt nicht beantworten, ob ein bestimmter Impfstoff funktioniert. Das müssen dann klinische Studien zeigen. Also.
Aus meiner Sicht sehe ich jetzt keine keine.
Kein Grund da in irgendeiner Weise die Deutschen Impfstoffe aus dem Feld rauszuheben, ne? Ähm sehr, sehr viele im Stoffkandidaten überall auf der Welt. Äh die deutschen Unternehmen.
Gehören dazu, aber ja wie gut das jetzt, wie gut die jetzt dastehen, also ganz ehrlich.
Kann ich nicht beantworten.
Ja gut, wollte jetzt auch gar keine Bewertung äh von dir haben, ne, sozusagen, um mal einzuordnen, äh welche welcher technische Weg hier äh verfolgt wird. Also man versucht's hier sozusagen mit dem
mit dem modernen äh potenziell vielversprechenden Ansatz, von dem man aber bisher einfach noch nicht weiß, ob es funktioniert. Man weiß nur, das funktioniert bei Mäusen, aber man hat eben noch keine konkreten Ergebnisse, aber diese Studie ist ja schon.
Also diese Erprobungsphasen sind schon relativ weit, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Also
dieses Dreiphasensystem, dass man erstmal äh guckt, okay, wir spritzen das mal an gesunde Leute äh und gucken mal, ob die gleich tot umfallen.
Äh wenn man dann äh erste Erkenntnisse über die Verträglichkeit gefunden hat, dann geht's halt los ähm.
Weiß gar nicht so genau, was die Rahmenbedingungen für die zweite Phase sind, aber das zumindest ein bisschen weit äh weiter auszuweiten, bis man das Gefühl, wo man dann auch sieht, okay, wird jetzt hier auch wirklich Antikörper gebildet, et cetera, also funktioniert das auch.
Das würde ja bedeuten, dass man eigentlich in dieser Phase drei auch schon die Erkenntnis haben müsste, dass eine Reaktion auch stattfindet im gewünschten Maße, oder?
Ja
ist natürlich bei Impfung, ein ganzes ganzes Stück komplizierter letztendlich ähm als zum Beispiel bei Medikamenten, wenn man eine Medikamentenstudie gibt, man gibt man den Leuten
den Kranken letztendlich in Phase drei das Medikament und guck, ob.
Besser performt als äh eine Kontrollgruppe oder als ein anderes Medikament, ob die Leute gesund werden oder nicht. Bei einer Impfung hat man hat man immer das
Problem, man impft gesunde und äh man muss dann überhaupt erstmal abwarten, bis sie mit dem.
Frontiert werden. Und deswegen sind ja auch sind ja auch viele Fachleute inzwischen.
Der Ansicht, dass es dass es eine ganz clevere Sache wäre, möglicherweise freiwillige, geimpfte
gezielt mit dem Corona Virus zu infizieren, um zu prüfen in welchem Ausmaß äh.
Diese diese Schutzwirkung funktioniert, da gibt's dann die ethische Debatte darf man in dem Fall Menschenversuche machen oder nicht. Ähm.
Ja, aber das große Problem ist eben, dass man im Zweifel äh in irgendeiner Weise abwarten muss.
Bis die Leute mit dem Gyros konfrontiert sind, was man unter normalen Umständen gar nicht beeinflussen kann, das heißt
dauert, man hat da auch nicht die perfekten Daten, wer jetzt genau mit dem Virus äh
konfrontiert war oder nicht, sondern man hat quasi eine Impfgruppe, man hat eine ungeimpfte Kontrollgruppe und
dann muss man gucken, dass die repräsentativ sind und dann muss man statistisch auswerten äh.
Ist unsere geimpfte Gruppe seltener krank geworden, es ist schwächer krank geworden, denn wie gesagt, wir können nicht erwarten, dass ein einer dieser Kohlevirus im Stoffe tatsächlich
komplett perfekt schützt. Ne, das heißt, wir müssen da mit sehr vielen
ja mit mit sehr vielen Versuchspersonen hantieren und dann eben auch eine sehr sorgfältige statistische Auswertung machen.
Dauert, das ist aufwendig, das ist teuer und dann ist natürlich die Frage, kann man sich das erlauben? Äh.
Dann ist die Frage, kann sich ein Unternehmen erlauben, dass dann bei der klinischen Studie im Zweifel ein negatives Ergebnis rauskommt, wenn man möglicherweise eben doch nochmal einen P-Wert drehen könnte? Also das sind
Das sind eben die Unwegbarkeiten.
Wir haben bei Impfstoffen einfach das Problem, dass wir nicht schnell und sicher und billig rauskriegen, ob der kaum funktioniert.
Mit anderen Worten, es wird teuer und es wird noch eine Weile dauern.
Ja ich weiß, ich weiß nicht, wahrscheinlich werden die Leute äh.
Die Zulassung von solchen Impfstoffen insgesamt beschleunigen, aber das bedeutet natürlich auch, dass die Chance
deutlich größer ist, dass man zum Beispiel auf ein falsch positives Studienergebnis durch statistische Effekte bekommt. Also, dass man, dass man eben wegen dieser beschleunigten Zulassung dann dem Stoff zulässt, der nicht funktioniert.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit steigt dadurch.
Was machen wir da jetzt draus? Also es gibt es gibt durchaus noch Potenzial für Optimismus aber äh oder nicht zwingend für für Pessimismus. Also es kann, kann immer noch alles ganz gut funktionieren,
Aber kann auch genauso noch sehr lange dauern, kann aber vielleicht auch am Ende gar nicht funktionieren.
Dass es am Ende gar nicht funktioniert, dass wir keinen im Stoff gegen Saatkopf zwei kriegen, das glaube ich nicht. Ich.
Denke, wir werden in den nächsten Monaten oder Jahren einen im Stoff haben, der dann auch nachweislich funktioniert äh.
Kurz bis Mitte fristig, also jetzt äh bis Sommer, Herbst zweitausendeinundzwanzig ist das alles ein bisschen unwegbar
einfach wie gesagt, wer diese Beschleunigung des Prozesses.
Unglaublich vielen Impfstoffkandidaten erhöhen natürlich ganz erheblich die Chance, dass wir schnell und auch effektiv an Funktionierenden Impfstoff bekommen. Auf der anderen Seite äh.
Erhöht natürlich die beschleunigte Zulassung auch die Chance, dass unter den mehreren Impfstoffkandidaten, die wir nachher haben werden auch einige sein werden, die einfach nicht funktionieren, weil die
Daten nicht gut genug waren, weil weil zum Beispiel falsch positive Ergebnisse dann in der Studie rausgekommen sind äh.
Ja in der Summe, das ist das ist denke ich das Wichtige, auch wenn es einen Impfstoff gibt.
Äh der dann im Großrausch pushaunt wird, dass wir ja jetzt alle gerettet sind. Äh wir werden.
Auf Weiteres nicht auf diese nicht pharmazeutischen Interventionen nennt man die, also die äh.
Maßnahmen wie Maskenpflicht, wie ein bisschen Kontaktreduzierung, äh Abstand halten und so weiter. Äh das
wird auch mit einem oder mehreren Impfstoffen, die wir in den nächsten Monaten haben, nicht überflüssig werden. Also es wird nicht so sein, dass ein Impfstoff kommt und ein Kehrwert zur Normalit
zurück.
Also zumindest nicht sofort.
Ja, zumindest zumindest nicht sofort. Natürlich wird die Panemie irgendwann vorbei sein. Sie wird zweitausendzweiundzwanzig aus meiner Sicht äh.
Sind wir damit durch, einfach aus den historischen Taten. Noch um zwei WM im Zweifel auch ohne im Stoff sind wir den Kram irgendwann los, ne.
Warum? Weil weil's dann einfach so viele Leute bekommen haben, dass wir dann wirklich äh so eine Art Herdenimulität haben oder warum.
Ich würde jetzt nicht den Begriff Herden Immunität benutzen aber
Irgendwann irgendwann kommen wir natürlich an dem Punkt, wo wir zehn, fünfzehn, zwanzig Prozent der Bevölkerung den Kram schon mal gehabt
dann dann haben wir ja mögliche Kreuze, Monität mit den humanen Korona Viren, das weiß man noch nicht so ganz. Aber natürlich, wenn wir, wenn wir jetzt eins, zwei, drei Wellen haben und das Ganze auch weltweit haben.
Dann.
Ja dein Sink natürlich auch jeweils beim Kontakt immer weiter die Chance des Virus auf einen der Kontakt zu treffen. Das ist ja nicht so nach dem Motto.
Wir haben die ganze Zeit normale Ausbreitung und dann kommt irgendwann der Schwellenwert und dann haben wir Herdenimmunität und dann ist das gar nicht mehr.
Sondern je mehr Leute
infiziert waren, je mehr Leute äh sich auch durch eigenes Verhalten schützen, desto schwieriger wird das für das Virus sich weiter zu verbreiten, desto langsamer verbreitet sich das Walter, desto niedriger ist der Level der Ansteckung
und desto geringer ist auch die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass wenn irgendwo dieses Corona-Sirus auftaucht, dass es dann.
Komische Aussprüche gibt, denn das Problem, das wir ja haben, ist, dass dieses Chorona-Virus große Ausbrüche verursachen kann äh.
Die dann eben wirtschaftliche Schäden verursachen, bei denen dann auch wieder mehr Menschen sterben und so. Also wir werden
da wurde ja schon ein paar Mal gesagt, früher oder später werden wir mit dem Virus leben können. Wir werden irgendwann andere Probleme haben, weil sich das irgendwann.
Ja irgendwann ist die Bevölkerung halt nicht mehr monologisch naiv, auch wenn man jetzt nicht fünfzig Prozent oder achtzig Prozent der Leute infiziert.
Aber da müsste man tatsächlich in die Pedimologen fragen, wie so eine historische äh
Grippe, Pandemie oder andere Panimien tatsächlich nachher ausgelaufen sind. Ne.
Nur historisch, nur historisch war irgendwann immer Schluss.
Oder es wurde halt zum Beispiel jede Grippepandymie hat ja auch ein Grippe in Saisonales Grippevirus hervorgebracht
dass uns dann über Jahre hinweg noch weiter begleitet hat, aber eben als saisonale Grippe,
Bei weitem nicht so schlimm war, wie eine pademische Grippe einfach wegen dieser wegen dieser neutralisierenden Infekts, dieser immer wieder auftretenden Infektionen.
Saß äh zwei wäre scheint auch nicht so mutationsfreudig zu sein, wie man das jetzt bei der Grippe kennt, ne? Also das war jetzt so jedes Jahr wieder eine neue Variante davon auftaucht, scheint eher nicht zu sein.
Also.
Das Ding bei der Grippe ist ja die Grippe hat ja ein segmentiertes Kino. Der falls diese dieses Erbgut liegt in Einzelteilen vor, die wenn jetzt zwei.
Unterschiedliche Grippeviren, ein Mensch oder ein Tier infizieren
ganz viele unterschiedliche Mischungen der Bestandteile dieser beiden Viren. Das bezeichnet man als sehr Kombination und das machen, das macht die Grippe und äh
Das Corona Viros hat eben kein segmentiertes Genom und hat deswegen nicht die Neigung zur Rekombination. Das heißt, die äh die jährliche Grippewelle äh.
Ist quasi ist quasi ein
Schrottschoss aus unglaublich vielen unterschiedlichen Influencer A Stämmen, verschiedenen Influencer B-Stämmen, die gehen ja nun auch schon seit Jahren und Jahrzehnten um die Welt. Also die saisonale Grippewelle
Das ist so ein Schrottschuss und äh
manchmal das Einstammen besonders relevant, manchmal ist möglicherweise andere andere Subtyp besonders relevant, das äh
wird immer, wie gesagt, wenn der Impfstoffentwicklung.
Ein Jahr im Voraus abgeschätzt, welcher Subtyp, welche Variante da besonders wichtig wird. Aber
Das ist ein Unterschied, da sind die äh die Grippe unterscheidet sich in dieser dieser allgemeinen Dynamik
total vom Corona Virus. Also ähm.
Wir werden bei Saskof zwei eben nicht diesen Schwurzschuss-Effekt haben, den man, den man bei der Grippe hat, einfach wir werden verschiedene Linien bekommen, aber.
Ob sie jetzt so im großen Stil die Wirkung eines Impfstoffs äh beeinflussen oder die Auswahl des Impfstoffs für das bei der Grippe der Fall ist.
Da
Das weiß ich nicht. Also ich glaube nicht, dass wir tatsächlich mit Saßkopf zwei in Zukunft umgehen müssen wie mit der Grippe. Möglicherweise haben wir tatsächlich irgendwann im Stoff
mit dem wir das Ding irgendwann loswerden. Also das ist ja bei der Grippe völlig unrealistisch.
Okay. Dann haben wir es ja dann tatsächlich noch geschafft, einen positiven äh äh Ausblick zu formulieren zu ändern.
Sowas in der Art zuminde.
Sowas in der Art. Es gilt natürlich nach wie vor, wir werden alle sterben, gar keine Frage, ja? Also das äh.
Das ist äh unveränderlich, aber äh zumindest äh nicht gleich alle morgen. Das ist da auch schon mal was.
Bleibt natürlich trotzdem die Gefahr, ne? Also selbst wenn wie du sagst, dass alles soweit in die Gesamtbevölkerung äh reingesickert ist, dass diese Ausbrüche sich in Grenzen halten.
Nicht, dass es weg ist, sondern es heißt äh es verbreitet sich halt nicht mehr so in dem Maße, ist eine, sagen wir mal eine Gefährdung wie so viele andere auch, die einen halt treffen können, aber bleibt natürlich die Gefährdung
für ältere Menschen, die einfach weniger Schutzmechanismen hochfahren können, wenn denn das Virus äh kommen. Von daher.
Wird es halt tendenziell eher eine Entlastung für jüngere Leute sein, aber bei älteren Leuten gilt es schon auch für längere Zeit, da die Schutzmechanismen hochzuhalten.
Ja, also bei älteren Leuten wird das natürlich ähm.
Wir sollten, wir sollten uns erinnern, ne, auch die auch die saisonale Grippe
der hat zwar eine, der hat zwar inzwischen eine geringere Sterblichkeit äh als Sargekopf zwei, aber auch die saisonale Grippe ist natürlich für Risikogruppen eine ganz erhebliche Bedrohung.
Die jedes Jahr wieder auftaucht und die durch die Impfung.
Abgemildert wird tatsächlich, aber äh es ist jetzt nicht so, dass das äh dass diese Bedrohung für die für die Risikogruppen durch Atemwegsinfek
schon durch Sage, Kopf zwei langfristig eine neue Qualität kriegen.
Kriegen wird. Also sie hat jetzt eine neue Qualität, weil wir in dieser Pandemie mit dem exklusiven Ausbrüchen sind, aber gefährliche Atemwegsinfektionen in Form der Grippe.
Haben wir laufend. Und insofern denke ich äh dass ich die.
Situation langfristig auch für Risikogruppen nicht so wahnsinnig ändern wird. Mit dem Unterschied natürlich, dass man.
Dass man erstmal auf einen Lebensstoff hier warten muss, wenn man ihn bei der Köppe halt schon hat.
Was natürlich auch noch sein kann ist, dass äh im medizinischen Bereich Fortschritte gemacht werden. Darüber haben wir jetzt hier gar nicht gesprochen, war nicht der Fokus, dass man einfach äh die Krankheit selbst besser äh behandeln kann und vielleicht, wenn man Glück hat
eben auch noch ein leicht abgeschwächter Virus, der vielleicht eingesehen hat, dass es äh nicht ganz so klug ist, um sich zu verbreiten, gleich alle umzubringen, sondern.
Vielleicht etwas milder zuzuschlagen.
Also das erste äh das erste mit der verbesserten Behandlung, das sehen wir bereits äh.
Sowohl mit medikamentöser Therapie als auch mit wesentlich
besseren Erfahrungen ähm mit dieser Krankheit. Und dann dann ist natürlich, wenn in Zukunft die Ausbrüche kleiner werden, dann hat man, dann hat man eben nicht mehr das
Problem, dass plötzlich das plötzlich so eine komplette Intensivstation mit Saßkoch zwei belegt ist. Äh vielleicht zwei, drei Leute da liegen. Und dann hat man eben auch die Behandlungskapazitäten, um besser zu behandeln. Also es spielt, es spielt alles so ein bisschen zusammen, aber langfristig
wird sich die Situation natürlich entspannen.
Super Lars. Ich würde sagen, an der Stelle können wir es erstmal ähm können wir das hier erstmal beenden. Vielleicht.
Sprechen wir über die weitere Entwicklung später nochmal.
Danke erstmal für die Ausführung. Ja und ähm ja, ich hoffe, das hat euch allen da draußen auch äh Neuigkeiten gegeben, wenn ihr Fragen habt rein in die Kommentare, äh damit.
Heute sage ich erstmal.